oh
my God this is crazy
we have sex we have sex we have sex we
have sex we have sex we have sex we have
sex
when was last time everybody had sex
yeah we tried this morning but something
died
two weeks ago only because I'm on my
period right now my period sucks
any kings that you guys like
um I love a little dirty talk I love a
little like little role play moment
I like like degrading and choking and
stuff like that
[Music]
I don't know I think I would like heat a
little more than like cold like candle
wet I don't know I'm scared of getting
burned too but if you guys are
comfortable with it try some like hot
chips like some hot Cheetos
love that eating a girl out with hot
Cheetos and ice and I just like that
didn't sound like something somebody who
is not a virgin would say
that's a good one that's cute
um it was on set yeah I
yeah
for a company
and they were like we're on set what
does that even mean yeah we're on set
now yeah that's true first day we went
to canes and then right after
for us it was like a month into dating
we both had like pretty rough
past experiences so we were trying to
like just do everything just be good
right and healthy forget about it yeah
he thought I was gay
[Laughter]
well it is I mean I was with girls
majority of the time before him and then
one night he was like okay so do you
want to or not and I was like yes I do I
was also living at her house for a week
beforehand trying to not and then it was
like it was worth it I just feel like
they were kind of awkward with each
other they weren't very like shoulder to
shoulder like a lot of the other couples
were what was your guys's like most
uncomfortable like sex moment like most
awkward if you had any we don't really
have that many like awkward moments
because we laugh a lot during sex
anyways yeah I feel like that's how it
is after like some time like you just
get like to a point where you just
giggle I think for us was when his mom
walked in like coming home from work it
was like right in the living room she
like opened the door and then just like
closed the shut and ever since then she
like knocks the door before she walks
into the house Eddie was like super
quiet so like it just felt like she was
kind of like taking control of the
situation so like I didn't feel that
connection really and they weren't
holding hands I caught him not holding
hands everybody else was after we got
together like going on spot and working
I feel like it was really different
because now we had like an intimate
connection versus just work yeah
were y'all hooking up before you got
together
and I guess we were getting paid to do
it there was one time where else about
their loss
[Laughter]
it's like so full and I was like the
motion would just kept on making me
dizzy what's like been your riskiest
sexual moment elevator
oh it was at my job and it was kind of
just like one of those buildings where
it has like multiple like buildings
inside of it yeah but it was like that
nobody really used the elevator so it
was always really risky every time and
we did it more than once thankfully
nothing happened to either one of them
[Music]
oh
damn we tried to give them a little hint
and I will say I think we were a little
bit quiet getting right on here I don't
know if it was awkward for her but it
was definitely awkward for me getting on
this type of set versus one that we're
used to with the directors we're used to
what's everyone's favorite sexual
position I like to be on top I like
doggy
eggs are up and he's like he's like on
top of the like eye contact I think
that's really cute missionary yeah
that's the thing is eye contact is the
most yeah like you can do it from the
back if you're like but you're like yeah
so yeah she was kind of new at sex with
women yeah and so I've been teaching her
what I knew before yeah learned a lot I
got a question okay
I'll put it like this I believe in God
but like it's more in a spiritual sense
I grew up really religious but I think
where I'm at now it's all more just like
spiritual yeah yeah things like that I
don't practice religion personally
what do you guys consider to be sex and
like do you consider your virginity to
be lost or like how does that work for
you that's an interesting question
that's like a Spacey question
honestly at the end of the day it's up
to everyone's like personal definitions
because like it doesn't matter what I
think for you or for you or anything but
like to me like oral sex isn't sex to me
because it's like you know that's like
that's a snack yeah I know that's
something yeah that's like the appetizer
she made a little comment and she I was
like I was like oh it's just a snack
it's just an appetizer and she was like
it's a tasty one and I was like ah okay
I think it was a little you're trying a
little much
for us no because
um my parents found out I was having
intercourse and having sex so like I
automatically went on birth control not
that long after I have the implant in my
arm so I never even with like that one
percent chance like I've never had any
sort of scares or had to worry about
anything like that and plan B yeah
I helped we had a plan B moment like it
was it like whereas like every other day
like you felt like because for us like
when we started like I didn't want him
to wear a condom because I wanted to
like actually feel like that connection
right yeah and so because of that we
were buying like Plan B like once or
twice a week she said something about
Plan B and just taking it so many times
I feel like someone that has had sex
multiple times and knows about Plan B
you're not supposed to take it that
often sometimes she would take a pill
and I'm like come on let's go like three
times yeah like minus one get the inside
of the pill
ow they were very very reserved Just In
This Very extroverted group about sex
they didn't really have too too much to
say
[Music]
we know our stuff we know our stuff
we're open about everything so it's kind
of like maybe we were too open and new
like what we wanted to say what we
wanted to say is so I felt like that was
like the bluntness is what got us out if
you guys think that the mole is still
within the cube and you want to continue
playing raise your hand on three one two
three
oh majority I can't okay what would
y'all say like how do you think it's
changed from the first time until now
basically like going into our
relationship and stuff I like had this
sort of idea of sex that was very it was
very like I didn't have that much
experience and it was sort of like I
thought of sex as like a performance I
think it was the same for for us like I
had like very like rough experiences and
I didn't want to like replicate that
when we started being together but then
we were just like very safe with each
other so I think it changed a lot in
like it's just more playful now I would
say what about for y'all yeah
yeah we are into a lot of things but at
some point she started to squirt and
okay we didn't even realize that was
something that could happen for a long
time because that's like some you know
what about you guys too can we keep it
Innocent but that makes it super super
like I used to like with previous
Partners I would be very like into like
the like tying up all that and then with
him he's more
[Music]
it's made it so much more like intimate
for a second I was like maybe they're
cousins
I don't know like beautiful brown eyed
babes like both of them kind of gave
the similar features yeah I want to
get to know you're
you're whatever
the moon we go no no
um
we should talk more about like what your
king says liking yeah he's really
aggressive
okay tell him like he has tied me up and
I was dead scared the first time so I
was like okay and then he got me into
slapping and stuff like that I was like
beat me more sorry but they just have
like a sort of interesting chemistry
that I'm not really there's something
yeah there's something there that like I
can't really pinpoint all right a little
less than two minutes
oh
[Music]
wait wait
this is crazy
oh my God I'm so sorry you got makeup on
me you're white wow we can demonstrate
this all day okay
this is fun actually cut the camera what
about this if you want a real question
30 seconds
it's essential for your relationship to
be at the point that you want it to be
oh it's necessary that's a good ass
question um
I think that it can and I think it's
when you do have a healthy relationship
sex should be a part of it if you're
comfortable with it sorry about lipstick
um yeah I think it should be part of it
right it can be incorporated and I think
you should have Intimacy in aspects of
all of those little things like yeah at
least we would need it to like balance
out all the different it's because it's
that interconnectedness that is like
almost physically seen and given I think
for us is exactly
[Music]
so the two couple on the line for the
tiebreaker are Armand and Reina
and Chloe and ren
what oh okay a month ago I bought a new
car and a lot and uh two weeks ago we
were gonna
have sex a new car my old car had like
um leather seats so there's another not
an issue but it had cloth and I woke up
the next day
yes
and then I have to go to Walmart
still there yeah yeah and yeah it's
still there today it was arrested yeah
and that's why I brought blankets today
well I mean we do have sex we had it
yesterday we had it the day before talk
about a time
that you want to talk about the kitchen
we we went to her parents house couple
months ago for like sorry my celebration
and
um so her parents had just made food and
everything and they're like couch is
right behind the kitchen and like I
literally like they just sat down and I
put Lauren like up against like the
counter and was like legit eating her
out with them right there and then she
told me later that from the angle we
were at if they were in the other room
they could see through into the kitchen
and it was it was hot though it was kind
of hot I'm not gonna lie
[Music]
count three if you think the mole is
still in the box and you want to keep
playing raise your hand okay yeah one
two three
oh no oh I think for us the couple we
thought that was the mole already like
stepped out like at some point so I
think at this point me and Josh were
just like over here getting ready I
think we just believe everyone's story I
feel like y'all have our all said stuff
that everyone looks like a couple sounds
really checked out I was trying to like
think about what like the liar was gonna
say what the mo was gonna say and y'all
all seem like pretty legit I mean I
believe well after hearing that I also
feel like it's probably fine if we don't
but yeah I think they voted yeah I just
I think needed
yeah
I was thinking we keep going we're just
gonna lose money yeah
let's stick with it how could humans
before the big reveal here's an even
bigger shout out to our partner Lilo for
sponsoring this video and for giving you
all up to 30 off select Milo products
even when they're on sale you may
already know that Lilo is an advocate
for breaking taboos and removing stigma
when it comes to sexual pleasure and
you'll see that with their luxury
products like Celia Cruz Celia Cruz is a
Sonic massager specifically designed for
sex toy beginners with Celia Cruz you
can truly follow your senses and find
out what feels good at your own pace
by incorporating Cruise technology it
provides a more controlled pleasure
Journey encouraging you to be in the
moment and allows you to give that extra
TLC to All Your Body Sensations we
invite you to check out lilo's website
for up to 30 off see the cruise and
select little products when you use the
promo code Jubilee at checkout and now
back to the episode
the Box turns green you guys are correct
and have correctly voted them all out if
the Box turns red the mole is still in
there with you guys will win all the
money to themselves are you ready
okay and on the count of three the moles
May step forward okay
one
two
three
[Applause]
so what's your story yeah so I'm Muslim
okay and so like sex is like not allowed
at all but it's like very controversial
like people say kissing is not allowed
the other stuff for me my belief I think
just like the sex like
I feel like just because we're not
intimately that way it doesn't mean that
he doesn't know me I feel like just
because we haven't been intimate he
knows me better than the people I have
been with also when you are married you
can have sex as much as you want and you
get rewarded for it
hey I'm cool and I directed this episode
of odd one out if you like this episode
and you want to see more subscribe to
our Channel
[Applause]
good job